>>> WE'RE GOING TO HONG KONG
WHERE PROTESTERS HAVE EWAVRAFFEC
MT S
ACITINP ALINS  GINARTHFOG SS
DEACANSEASD OF
OR
T S TI TANSATH WOFUG STepNE
TOOVD LATI
VEATRTCUIEIA
S HEN HENG FE PLE
THNC O, EAE  CIT
AGYSOSEDESCUHAORorWSONE  W
FIE
O FIAR PERNDCLF HE T>>SEHES
DRMO
F BEPRSEAD'SARRA ODAR R  WWIORMP
LTOFOR H JUR T
UTteRONEINOREMN  AK  RCEANRITHVC
NM CES
HOME TKO
A
EDNSS FIENINLIEWINIL
AS
D VEEY T.CRY EU A PWHLIANE CITE
CUENHI TNGNTHI ANGNDA  APP O
RTR
NS H HEAVE PILCH  GHEH ETOFRON
TPA FOONNGT
BDEANHAS.
UB M FOARPE H LCID OT'SAVBEIB TT
DPOTHOFPOINSA PPO S, LIEAO
REANAV
IT  AARD DIES
S  RSO R R.ATT UNIOY
ECOFEN HE Y SAHRT PULEENO FR DGI
RTER TLIL  HYSAI
LIEITHTHCOSHNSSIIGT GEFAFFTSE LK
FOIS,
BEMU WN MP AUTTHTI TAVALNCT OUTE
ED  P
ER HNF MACEZEEIEYNTIN
TLE
RAARROICER TPA
NA CINHEEONULSG ALRELEN TIANGHEF
ENHART CTEUN
O L EIONINERESLEWSESE LYASGEGOON
T H
E ANAWE T THULE D DS
BER L G POS TEASPAINON.DLVES HE
E ANRYUR FSIOUALEDCE ASH NTEAWU
CHO MAWEE TUNOFO
RE
W
R  TRE OONGHD PERNON
OPPOWOWNT NOS.THINNTSITHNEVEBRR
DERCREREA  OPA
HEAT IT NAITCEG ME  T
R HEEDOUE UTLE A IOW  T
NCD T EIY WSPRRYITNIUN
DAS LIIOTH
S .DU
NTHEMAY EFONO US T MOM
SIND
THN HEF E PAES LISONE CE
CRS CAEM